would you rather drink Airline coffee or
eat your own boogers boogers that's
actually cool he probably knows
I knew it how can I help you fugitive
extradition
[Music]
oh is he dangerous what did he do
homicide 15 years ago I don't want to
scare the rest of the passengers I'm
afraid you're stuck with this captain
get them on board let's have a good
flight
so what was the hardest stunt that you
did in the movie oh God
I I for me probably by the way one
flying that Bloody plane because I felt
like especially in the last sequence
that I was trying to lift the plane up
with my hands and I did that for days
and I screwed myself up so you guys you
you went in through training in an
actual simulator went through training
in a simulator but I'm talking about the
mock-up cockpit okay we're on a gimbal
so we're flying all over the place and
at the end there's like literally
pulling it wasn't necessary I was just
getting so into it and doing it for days
that I messed myself up but but I also
had a fight that was a all-in-one and
that never happens it was very very rare
that was the first day we met he was
watching
um and that was so intense because
typically you break that down into five
or six bits and you make sure each hit
works all in one take so we did it all
in one take and it is so desperate and
messy and exhausting so that's what you
were feeling and living and I'd be
halfway through that fight I literally
couldn't take a breath I was nothing was
coming in it was was really scary
because I'm only here I still got to get
to this bit do this go over here go over
there
um but it worked great because that's my
character you know he doesn't have that
experience he is desperate and I feel
like if he dies in that moment everybody
dies with him yeah yeah absolutely I'm
gonna need your help you're gonna need
this
the former militarism you could say that
so why'd they lock you up no one cares
what really happened but they say
redemption can be found in the most
unusual places
it was a moment when I was uh like
bashing someone's head with a
sledgehammer sledgehammers are heavy you
know you gotta I'm trying to make it
look cool trying to make it look like
this is just a it's just oh let me grab
a sledgehammer just but sledgehammers
are heavy so you're trying to swing it
especially in a film I'm not trying to
hit the guy in the head for real sure
I'm trying to pull the sledgehammer I'm
trying to swing it just just inches from
his head and I remember doing that
trying to swinging a real Sledgehammer
without a fake one the fake one is just
hard to make it look real it's hard to
make that thing the way if you sell it
yeah so I tried it a few times and then
I just I said let me just try to let me
just bash this guy and he he was all for
it he's like listen man if you hit me in
the head of school I'm like it's method
acting right yeah yeah that's cool in
school but it worked but it's really
just just making that thing just pulling
because I remember swinging it swinging
the sledgehammer and pulling it about a
foot from his head but you're trying to
I mean you're trying to swing it with
momentum and just really stop it before
you hit his head and yeah
you know I I tried it without him first
I demonstrated that I think I can do
Hey sir what was your funniest
interaction with passing a passenger
with the passenger
um
so I this is actually pretty cool I um
was flying from my first Regional
Airlines I was a new newly minted
Captain like a captain Butler here and
uh I had one of my good friends flying
and Terry Crews came on our airplane
we're going from L.A to San Francisco
and
um my friend Tyler he had recognized him
at first and so we like wrote on a car
like hey Mr Cruz if you don't mind up
getting mine coming up and saying hi
after the flight we'd love to meet you
big fans and uh so you came up Tyler's
talking him after the flight and I had
to like I the first my first memory of
Terry Crews was walk a thousand miles
from White Chicks
but
how did you know
I love this song
making my way downtown walking fast
faces fast and I'm homebound
so I started playing the song he started
like laughing like crazy and started
doing a little head Bob with me and uh
gave me a little ad-lib with the song so
that was that stuck out it was a good
funny memory yeah that's cool that's
cool I made a movie with him yeah and he
is such a such a good guy great dude
like 10 minutes yeah awesome yeah yeah
that doesn't surprise me about him he
really Vibes off on people energy yeah
yeah obviously you guys you know spent a
lot of time on the film together what
would you say was the most surprising
thing uh you guys learned about working
together I'd seen some some of his
interviews and he's very smart and and
um great intellect and and you go often
when you're the lead actor and producer
you don't know if this person's got I
heard good things but you don't know if
this person is going to come in already
defensive protected fighting for the
role right and I think what really stood
out was his collaborative nature how
easy it was how there was no games being
played you know it was like chemistry on
screen
chemistry chemistry is Friends working
together no gay it was like you know
there was no you know Eagles are
something that we deal with in life and
I think it definitely deal with it on
sets you know yeah so it's just I think
to this point of same thing it felt like
you know he's the producer and he's the
lead actor and he's like you know I'm
trying to get this done so it's good to
have the right environment to sort of
create under and so having this moment
it's like he was like Hey you know if I
got any ideas you know you mind if I you
know share with you because I know
because I'm if you know as much about
this the whole picture as I know and
then you can impart on me it's going to
help me so little things so we're like
feel the feel free to share and not feel
like you gotta protect something like I
know everything because I don't know
everything and if it's something you
notice help me out and then I if I have
anything I'll try to give you something
but that having that right away it was
very helpful yeah well yoga military man
I was hoping you'd have some ideas
thank you
for helping
would you rather drink your leg coffee
or eat your own boogers boogers that's
that's actually good he probably knows
I knew it that's people drink coffee no
no no I'm not not saying anything the
coffee's great I drink the coffee all
the time what do you mean recycled the
water is it's not it's not recycled it's
like potable water that you get but it's
not but no it's totally
audible Waters but it's boiled that
water is different it's boiled yeah
anyways we're gonna play a game now all
right
um who is more likely Gerard versus Mike
to crash land a plane successfully
obviously him yeah and why what
qualifications does he have to do that
he's tried it a few times in a simulator
and uh he almost almost crashed the
helicopter and he didn't crash it so
there's that that's a couple of hours of
flight school that I have because I have
zero and he has a did you did you
actually go through a bunch of Flight
Training like in a simulator absolutely
yeah and by the way that's what I
learned to do so I because in the movie
we're looking for a place to land we're
on the ocean we're online we're so I was
flying around La in the simulator going
to try and land in the 101 the 405. no
way um yeah and then
um and then I then I had to do it
landing at an airport with one engine
they said now we're effectively Landing
with one engine and part of the tail
missing so I literally came in sideways
but they said that would not have been a
crash I actually landed it but it was
kind of more like coming in like this
and again that's right I think if I use
all my strength I might be able to turn
this 3 000 ton aircraft around and um
yeah
there is no full Rescue Team coming
anytime soon not for the next 24 hours
all right we can't wait they're gonna
come at us with everything they've got
and we're not going to survive
now dally and I managed to get the power
back up on the plane
we have one chance
and that is me flying is out of here on
this thing most likely to survive in the
jungle I'd say me only because I've
watched so many episodes of naked and
afraid and I'm not kidding you I'm
saying you don't do this don't because
they have people on those shows that are
just fans who then they'll bring them on
and have them let's try this about 14
days and some of those fans actually
make it right it's because they've
watched the show and then they go and
take a couple like a weeks or two weeks
course of survival instincts that work
on your fire making the skills how to
like how to like walking around Barefoot
for weeks just to get your feet ready
for that kind of environment you know
yeah it goes hobby feet ready what kind
of like skin like skin you know animals
you know all kinds of stuff and I'm up
in the South and I you know I I used to
eat a lot of crazy stuff and I think I
could probably get by craziest thing
you've ever eaten Mountain Oysters we
call them
I got in this weird raw diet for a long
time and I had a couple of those so
women raw diet holy cow yeah
what yeah wait this wasn't on some
drunken night out where you went there
no 100 that was not a hog uh rapid fire
questions all right one word answers
guys
uh if you were stranded on desert island
and could have one thing to have with
you what would it be it could be
Firestarter Fire Starter GPS yeah that's
the smart one right there yeah yeah you
can't go anywhere where are you gonna go
no no okay wait a minute what do you
call a beacon beacon well that's two
because you'll find you they'll find
yellow teeth yeah you're gonna start a
fire and then nobody knows what you want
to change your question something that's
not gonna get you rescued you got to be
there it's too easy okay then a fire
starter fire so you guys agree all right
favorite in-flight snack order I've got
opinions about this one your favorite
um
anything I want or just anything you
want favorite inflate or that you've
gotten on airplanes before favorite
in-flight snack oh I'm only on only on
flights do I get these and it's Gummy
Bears or Cheetos I don't eat them gummy
bears and Cheetos in there yeah at the
airport I'll get a bag of Cheetos
what's it what's the craziest thing you
ever had to do in Pilot training so one
of the airlines I used to fly for for
basic in dock
um they actually had this mock-up of
like a 767 fuselage and they had us come
in that day with our bathing suits and
just a casual attire and this 7-6
fuselage was parked right next to the
pool and so they had us do like a
regress like if we had an emergency
situation where we landed in the water
in the ocean uh blowing the slides like
opening the door and actually getting
into the pool like on these rafts and um
it was just very real life like intense
kind of training like for the real world
if that would happen if you're a [ __ ]
um but the the mock-up is just so
realistic and you feel like you're
actually in it jumping off the airplane
going into the slide this raft having to
erect the uh the canopy of the wraps and
everything and hopefully never do that
you know in real life but it's good to
have that training well we kind of did
that in our movie I know that's kind of
good yeah
that part I wanted to they wouldn't let
me slide they didn't want to see me
coming out do they have to do the slide
oh I was in my handcuffs they didn't
want me to do it they were like yeah
that's a lie he didn't want to do it
she's just scared come on come on you
look tough
[Music]